Sex die meisten tun es und wir sind alle
ständig davon umgeben im Filmen und
Serien Literatur und Werbung sexualität
ist für viele ein wichtiger Teil ihrer
Persönlichkeit sie ist ein Instrument
der Unterdrückung aber auch der
Selbstbestimmung und nicht zuletzt
natürlich auch wichtig um als
Gesellschaft überhaupt zu überleben mit
anderen Worten Sex ist überall aber auch
im All das ging nach einer lustigen
nicht ganz so ernst zu nehmenden Frage
ist aber tatsächlich ein wichtiges
Forschungsfeld das nicht genug Beachtung
findet und genau deswegen gehen wir der
Sache auf den Grund herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen Folge dr Watson
okay reden wir nicht lange drumherum wie
ist das haben astronautinnen und
Astronauten Sex also da oben dafür das
Raumstationen wie die ISS quasi komplett
videoüberwacht sind bleibt die Antwort
überraschend unklar es gibt genau zwei
Missionen in der Geschichte der
Raumfahrt die für potenzielle
sexexperimente Experimente in Frage
kommen zumindest hetero
1992 schickte die NASA Nancy Jane Davis
und Mark Lee ins All was die beiden
ihrem Arbeitgeber aber verheimlichten
kurz vor ihrem Staat hatten sie
geheiratet für die beiden Astronauten
die sich bei der NASA kennengelernt
hatten waren die Tage im
US-amerikanischen space Lab quasi
heimliche Flitterwochen da hört die
Geschichte allerdings auch schon auf das
Gerücht dass die beiden Sex hatten
basiert rein darauf dass die beiden ein
Paar waren konkreter wird es da schon im
Fall von Svetlana saviskaja Leonid Popov
und Alexander serebrov sie schlossen
sich 19 89 also bereits zehn Jahre
vorher zwei weiteren Astronauten auf der
russischen Raumstation saloud 1 an der
deutsche Astronaut Ulrich Walter
schreibt in seinem Buch dass es hier zum
ersten Geschlechtsverkehr im allgekommen
sei das hätte ihm der damalige russische
Teamarzt so gesagt und auch dass man
damals das erste Gemisch geschlechtliche
Team unter anderem genau deswegen
bewusst zusammenstellte so richtig
offiziell sind diese Informationen aber
nicht die raumfahrtbehörden selbst
schweigen sich zu diesen Theorien
nämlich aus mehr noch die NASA behaart
darauf dass es in der Geschichte der
US-amerikanischen Raumfahrt keinen
einzigen Fall von sexuellen Begegnungen
auf Missionen gegeben hat begründet wird
das auch von Astronauten der ESA
übrigens immer mit einem nein nein
unsere Astronauten sind Profis aha an
Bord wird gefälligst gearbeitet und
geforscht da bleibt keine Zeit für
irgendwelches Techtelmechtel klingt im
ersten Moment logisch doch diese
sexangst der NASA und Isa könnte
tatsächlich problematisch sein aber
bevor wir dazu kommen da mal ganz kurz
zur Praxis wenn tatsächlich ist Sex im
Weltall gar nicht mal so einfach
umzusetzen wie gesagt der begrenzte
Platz in Stationen wie der ISS ist quasi
komplett überwacht da ist das mit der
Privatsphäre so eine Sache die
vielleicht noch größeren Hürden haben
aber wie bei so vielen Aktivitäten da
oben mit der Schwerelosigkeit zu tun zum
einen ist da die Impulsübertragung jede
Bewegung befördert die raumfahrerinnen
und Raumfahrer potenziell durch den
ganzen Raum
okay also entweder gut fixieren oder
halt weniger Körpereinsatz wenn es nur
das ist leider könnte es bereits bei
unseren Körperfunktionen scheitern schon
die Durchblutung und damit die Erektion
der Geschlechtsteile funktionieren ohne
Schwerkraft ziemlich sicher nicht so
problemlos das Paper dazu findet
übrigens auch in der Videobeschreibung
wenn euch damit weiter befassen wollt
außerdem gibt es Hinweise darauf dass
Mikrogravitation wie sie auf
Raumstationen herrscht sogar den
Hormonhaushalt durcheinanderbringen kann
eine Studie hat das bereits für Hormone
zur Knochenbildung nachgewiesen ob sich
das auch auf unsere Sexualhormone
auswirkt oder auf die Hormone die unsere
Lust steuern ist allerdings noch nicht
wirklich erforscht und damit sind wir
wieder beim Hauptproblem denn damit
diese Dinge ordentlich erforscht werden
können wäre es ja hilfreich wenn die
großen raumfahrtbehörden diesem Thema
nicht mehr auswichen nur so können wir
Antworten auf die vielen Fragen rund um
diesen wesentlichen Bestandteil der
menschlichen Natur finden das Human
research Programm der NASA selbst führt
eine Liste der 5 größten Gefahren die
die Raumfahrt bereithält darunter auch
das Gefühl der Isolation um dieses
Gefühl zu überwinden könnte es doch
helfen zumindest die Möglichkeit für
körperliche Nähe und Intimität zu
diskutieren oder Hautkontakt ist nicht
nur extrem wichtig für die richtige
Entwicklung von Kindern sondern hat
beispielsweise auch nachweislich
positive Effekte auf die Gesundheit
erwachsener Menschen das gilt schon für
Dinge wie Umarmungen aber auch
Sexualität jeder Art verbessert unser
immun und Herz-Kreislauf-System lindert
Stress steuert unseren Hormonhaushalt
und trägt zu gesundem Schlaf bei alles
Dinge die im tödlichen Vakuum des
Weltalls ziemlich praktisch sind oder
dazu kommt auch das astronautinnen und
Astronauten immer mehr Zeit auf engstem
Raum mit wenigen Menschen verbringen
Menschen mit denen sie intensive und
stimulierende Arbeit machen das könnte
die Lust an und Wichtigkeit von
Intimität ja sogar noch steigern wo wir
gerade von Lust sprechen ich habe mega
Lust auf was leckeres zu Essen mit
diesem eleganten Übergang kommen wir zum
Sponsor des heutigen Videos cool die
haben ist nämlich ein riesiges care
package mit ganz vielen schulprodukten
zum Testen geschickt neben dem T-Shirt
danke schön gab zum Beispiel zwei große
Packungen suel Pulver nämlich einmal
sollte Caramel und einmal Vanille mein
Favorit ist Vanille und den passenden
Shaker gab es auch direkt dazu ich mix
das immer mit Wasser und trinkt das
jetzt seit einigen Tagen zum Frühstück
du findest sehr lecker aber auch
Mittagessen kann Joule hier zum Beispiel
Pasta Bolognese kann man sehr schnell
zubereiten ist gesund hat zum Beispiel
sehr viele Proteine und kostet pro
Mahlzeit nur 3,21 € was ziemlich günstig
ist wenn ihr jetzt auf den ersten Link
unten in der Videobeschreibung klickst
dann könnt ihr auch cool food nach Hause
geliefert bekommen eine Erklärung für
die merkwürdige brüderie der NASA könnte
sein dass die US-amerikanische Behörde
öffentlich finanziert wird es wäre nicht
das erste Mal dass Bürokratie oder
politische Umstände den Fortschritt bei
der NASA ausbremsen oder auch generell
den Fortschritt von Wissenschaft
insbesondere in den USA kann ich mir
vorstellen dass die konservative und
christlich gepräg Politik einen Einfluss
hat aber auch die ESA oder rosskosmos
sind auf öffentliche Gelder angewiesen
da hält man sich vielleicht lieber
bedeckt was so furchteinflößen
polarisierende Themen angeht wie Sex
aber was ist denn dann mit der privaten
Raumfahrt SpaceX und Co sind ja nicht im
selben Maße von der Öffentlichkeit
abhängig und haben damit häufig einen
entscheidenden Innovationsvorsprung
gegenüber der klassischen Institutionen
zu dem Thema haben übrigens auch schon
hier ein Video gemacht fakt ist aber
auch von einem Elon Musk oder Jeff Bezos
kam bisher wenig zur menschlichen Ebene
der Raumfahrt und Sir Richard Branson
naja dabei sind jetzt gerade ihre
Ambitionen die die Diskussion eigentlich
wieder so richtig anheizen müssten
Weltraumtourismus monatelange Reisen zu
und letztendlich Leben auf neuen
Planeten sobald wir über den
raumstationsrand hinausschauen wird klar
welche Rolle zwischen Menschlichkeit im
All mal haben könnte wenn wir darüber
sprechen als multiplanetare Zivilisation
langfristig überleben zu wollen dann
kommen wir natürlich nicht drumherum
Leistungsaspekt zu sprechen wie wirkt
sich die stärkere Strahlung im Weltraum
langfristig auf Geschlechtszellen oder
Reproduktionsorgane aus wie entwickeln
sich Kinder aber auch der Körper von
Erwachsenen unter anderem
gravitationsbedingungen hier gibt es
viele Lücken und bisher scheinen es die
großen Behörden nicht wirklich eilig zu
haben diese zu schließen die meisten
Experimente zur reproduktiven Gesundheit
im All beschränken sich bisher auf
wenige Tierversuche 2018 wurden im
Rahmen des Projekts Micro eleven
erstmals auch menschliche Sperma Proben
auf die ISS geschickt um die
Bewegungsfähigkeit der Spermien in der
Schwerelosigkeit zu erforschen und
leider konnten wir trotz ausgiebiger
Recherche keine weiteren Infos dazu
finden was dabei herausgekommen ist
unter anderem aus diesen Gründen hat ein
Team aus fünf kanadischen Forschenden
letztes Jahr ein Paper veröffentlicht
indem sie dazu aufrufen space sexology
mehr in den Fokus zu rücken der Antrag
erschien im dezember 2021 und richtete
sich direkt an die großen
Raumfahrtagenturen die Forschenden
kritisieren dass es bisher keine
gezielten Bemühungen gibt die
Umsetzbarkeit und vor allem die
Bedeutung von Sex und Intimität auf
mehrjährigen Missionen im All auszuloten
dabei geht es nicht rein um
Fortpflanzung sondern vor allem um die
psychische und physische Gesundheit
einer Gesellschaft zu der auch eine
gesunde sexualität gehört unabhängig von
Geschlecht gender oder sexuelle
Orientierung und das finde ich
persönlich den wichtigsten Take Away
während wir uns in fortpflanzungsfragen
wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie mit Dingen
wie künstlicher Befruchtung und
Brutkästen behelfen könnten ist die
zwischenmenschliche Ebene von Intimität
sehr komplex und nicht mal eben schnell
mit ein paar Gadgets gelöst wenn wir
langfristig planen auf einem Planeten
wie dem Mars Fuß zu fassen müssen wir
über diese Dinge sprechen und sie
erforschen auch wenn wir es hier etwas
einfacher haben als auf einer
Raumstation zum Beispiel was die
Gravitation angeht herrschen auf dem
roten Planeten trotzdem noch teilweise
ziemlich lebenswidrige Bedingungen ein
soziales Miteinander und menschliche
Bindungen könnten so zu einem noch
wichtigeren gut werden als sie es
ohnehin schon sind
um es mit den Worten von Dr Chris
Lenhardt zu sagen der ein leitender
Mediziner im Johnson Space Center der
NASA ist alle sind immer auf die
Hardware fokussiert die es braucht um
auf den Mars zu kommen aber wer das
menschliche System in all diesen Plänen
und Designs ausblendet wird am Ende
scheitern
Probleme in der Raumfahrt sind dabei
vielleicht auch nur symptomatisch für
den generell schwierigen Stand von Sex
und Sex Positivismus in unserer
westlichen Gesellschaft aber auch
insbesondere in der Wissenschaft wie ich
hier immer wieder angedeutet habe Sex
ist politisch zur Emanzipation vieler
Minderheiten gehört über die eigene
Sexualität verfügen zu können und
darüber verfügen zu können heißt auch
sie besser zu verstehen aber bis heute
ist es schwierig zum Beispiel Studien zu
Erforschung des weiblichen Orgasmus
finanziert zu bekommen ganz abgesehen
davon dass man sich womöglich dem Sport
der Forschungsgemeinschaft aussetzt weil
Sex nach wie vor weitläufig als
unwichtig und der Umgang damit als
unprofessionell abgetan wird und auch
Personen außerhalb der heterosexuellen
zissgeschlechtlichen Normen Ringen darum
in der Wissenschaft gehört zu werden das
sollte sich ändern wenn man sich
anschaut wie viele positive Effekte
schon jetzt mit Sex und der Vielfalt von
sexuellen Ausdruck verbunden werden mal
schauen was wir noch alles finden wenn
wir erst richtig danach suchen deswegen
bleibt Neugier IG euer Cedric